&gt;&gt; If I add my equations together, I get 13x equals 26. Positive 8y and negative
8y eliminate. They add to zero. Then, we divide both sides by 13. So, I know x
is equal to 2. I found x, so now, I need to find y. I'm going to use this first
equation, and write it over here, so I can substitute the value of x, which is 2
into this equation. So, plugging in a value of 2 for x, I get 7 times 2, which
is 14. The rest of my equation stays the same. I subtract 14 from both sides to
get 8y equals negative 8. Remember, I have more negatives than positives here,
so definitely negative 8. Then, we divide both sides by 8 to get y equals
negative 1. We write a solution as a point. I'm not going to show the check for
this equation but you can always double check your answer.